welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and coming to you
live from the fortress of spoiler Jude
with some brand new Batman updates this
episode were breaking down to big
exclusives that have been sent to us by
the fan community and both provides some
really exciting news in the first part
of the video we'll be discussing some
brand new plot leaks and in the second
we'll be dissecting an insane detail
that a fan noticed on the Batsuit itself
there will be heavy spoilers here so if
you want to go into the movie as blind
as a bat then I highly recommend that
you check out right now whilst all leaks
like this should be taken with a pinch
of salt they do definitely line up with
things that we've heard on the project
so they seem to make a lot of sense
still though I wouldn't want to ruin the
movie for anyone so yeah get the hell
out of here if you don't want anything
spoiled if you enjoy the video then
please drop a thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe to the channel for videos
on the Batman every week without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into our breakdown of the Batman
plot week's okay so if you cast your
mind back to a couple of months ago
before the world went to crap then you
might remember that we did a video on
some exclusive Batman plot leaks that
was sent to us by insiders these
confirmed that the upcoming Batman movie
was going to be heavily based upon the
earth 1 graphic novel by Geoff Johns
what added weight to this was the fact
that the message pointed out two things
that no other fans have noticed up until
that point the first of which was that
Batman is not a hero was written on the
back of the book Robert Pattinson got a
lot of backlash for saying this in an
interview however no one outside of this
message had noticed that it had come
directly from the back of the book which
Pattinson had reportedly been given as
something to study to get into character
on top of this it also brought the use
of vengeance in the work which as we
know had been used on some actors chairs
I don't want to just recap all of that
video but I did fully check out
everything about the message just to
make sure it was true before posting I
tried to be as cautious as possible with
my leaks before I put them live as it
makes me look bad if I get things wrong
now so what I'm basically saying is that
if I was Joe Chill I would have shot the
kid too you know just to be on the safe
side but still take these leaks with a
pinch of
salt as we won't know for definite until
we see the movie for ourselves now the
message that I received late last week
takes the initial elements of the
aforementioned pot leaks and builds upon
them in several ways flashing out
certain things and having weight to the
aspects that we've already theorized
upon the person who sent me this message
has asked me to blur out their name but
obviously huge shout out to them for
sending it they said my friend who works
in the moviemaking industry know some
things about the new Batman movie
directed by Matt Reeves the Riddler who
is the main villain will be very similar
to the earth one version of the
character he'll be responsible for the
death of the mayor which will lead to a
power struggle between several Gotham
politicians including Oswald Cobblepot
Batman will also fight firefly who will
be the Riddler's bodyguard in this movie
the riddle trophies from the Arkham
games will also be included in the movie
they'll be left behind by the Riddler at
every crime scene Gill :
the Gotham District Attorney will be
based off of Janice Porter a character
from Batman victory we also see Jim
Gordon making his way up the ranks to be
police commissioner you're an awesome
man and keep doing these amazing videos
I left that bit and at the end I make
myself feel better but there's a lot to
take from that and firstly we obviously
know that the Riddler is the main
villain but the fact that he murders the
mayor is something that we've kind of
pondered over quite a bit I can't
believe I used the word ponder this
should call me the Pandora now subreddit
DCE leaks did possess a post a couple of
months ago was saying that the big crime
scene that had so many news vans around
it was actually due to the death of the
mayor this was given more weight when
the funeral scene was supposedly meant
to be for him too so everything seems to
be kind of lining up towards that
direction also due to the fact that bela
rial is listed as a mayoral candidate on
IMDb many fans including myself have
ponderize that there will be a power
struggle in gotham for the position in
the wake of his death which this message
definitely backs up the message then
goes on to say that Firefly will be the
Riddler's bodyguard though we don't know
for definite whether this is the case
it's interesting to know that there was
a casting call for a minion of the
character known as the bright
you don't have to be Edward nygma to
figure out that he and the brain are
probably the same so this is a nice
little detail that kind of ties the two
points together there is going to be a
fire chief in the film
so having firefly in it at some point
does make a lot of sense and thus these
leaks see more likely it has been long
thought that Firefly would be in the
film and this message lines up a lot
with that I also love that according to
this leak there is going to be Riddler
trophies in the film and that's
definitely a cool little Easter egg I'll
be keeping an eye out for another
interesting aspect is that Gil Coulson
will be based upon Janice Porter a
prominent character from dark victory in
that book she took over the position of
the DA and the wake of Hobby dent
becoming two-faced and now I don't think
that this aspect will be in the film I
do you think that the darker side of her
character will be within Colson Porter
was obsessed with Dent and it is
possible that this could be a motif that
pops up in the film itself making for an
interesting dynamic should the character
appear Porter was investigating the
crimes of the hangman the serial killer
in the work and she was eventually
killed by dent but I think in this film
it might be the Riddler finally is the
point that Gordon will be working his
way up to commissioner and I definitely
think that this is true as in a recent
interview with Jeffrey Wright when asked
how it felt to be playing Commissioner
Gordon he corrected it by saying that he
was just playing Gordon I do you think
that this plot leak seems legit and I am
willing to hold my hands up if it's
wrong but after comparing it to other
things we know about the film it
definitely seemed correct if you don't
know the channel wanting to cover these
leaks then go ahead and do it as I'd
love to see this story pick up some
steam but please shout us out as it
helps us to keep bringing exclusive news
like this also if you do it yeah can you
please refer to me as the spoiler man
from the fortress of spoiler tude and
then elixir yours free of charge anyone
who calls me heavy spoilers will be
copyright strike and taken to court
believe that anyway before we get into
the rest of the video I just want to let
you know we're giving away a free copy
of the Marvel phase three part two box
set to one random subscriber all you
have to do to being with a chance of
winning is like the video subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
the leaks in the comments
section below the winners gonna be
chosen at random on the 15th of June and
the cell be shipped out from then Tova
gets the prize so best of luck to
everyone who takes part okay so the
second part of the video we're gonna be
breaking down a mysterious part of the
new bat suit that could indicate
something very very enraging or am I not
now I'll just say that this person who
sent this in thinks that Batman may just
may be using a gun in the movie now
before you start smashing the keyboard I
will say I disagree with this usage and
have an alternate theory but of course
shout out Simon and van ghoul for
bringing this to my attention as I
definitely didn't notice it and you
should be proud of yourself for spotting
it now as for the message Simon Says hit
that like button I'm just kidding not
really Simon Says so I'm not a leaker or
anything but I love scanning heavily
over leaked images and putting ish
together first I identified one of the
pouches there are actually at least two
of this set on the belt and it's a
goddamn 9 millimeter clip pouch we can
also see he has an off-the-shelf drop
holster on his hip I find it interesting
the pouch is empty in the set leaks
could this be they didn't want people to
freak out over the reveal that Batman
uses a firearm not sure if this is
something worth talking about on your
show but shout out van ghoul if you want
to talk about this no problem if you
don't keep making good vids I left that
bit in the end to make myself feel
better however they are indeed right
about this and there are clearly some
horses on his hip typically used for
housing a 9-millimeter clip now I got
this email sent on the 3rd of June and
I've been thinking back and forth over
what it could be
I don't think that this is 4 & 9
millimeter per se however I do think
that the holster is there to house a gun
namely Batman's grappling hook Batman of
course uses the grapnel gun to get
around the city and the way that the DIY
aspects of the suit have been put
together it is possible that he's
modified a 9-millimeter itself in order
to become his new grappling gun if that
is the case then you can see why they
would hide this from the bike chase and
stuff as it might cause people to freak
out immediately without knowing the full
context of its use Batman did use guns
early on in the comics
but since then he's moved away from it
unless there are no bloody tank am i
right and I think the creative team
would know the backlash you would be in
coming so they hit it this seems strange
to have a nine-millimeter pouch for any
reason other than to house a gun and
after thinking on it long and hard this
is the conclusion that makes the most
sense for me so again thank you van
ghoul and also the other person for
sending the leaks who who wanted to
remain anonymous the Batman is
definitely shaping up to be something
special with these leaks and hey I hope
you enjoyed the video
now obviously had loved hear your
thoughts on the leaks and what your
theories are comment below and let me
know and if you missed our breakdown of
the new Batman updates this week and
make sure you check it out after this we
go over some brand new Batmobile details
and talk about the film in general in a
far more exciting way that I'm selling
to you right now if you want to support
the channel from as little as 99 cents a
month then please click the join button
below
we massively appreciate you it and as a
thank you you get access to content
early we're gonna come chat to us after
the show either follow us at heavy
spoilers or click the discord link in
the description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with us so
hopefully we see over there very soon
this is a channel for people who are
super into superheroes so if that's the
kind of thing you like hit subscribe
thank you for taking the time to watch
this I've been definition you've been
the best I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]